and one of the West Oxfordshire
conservatives this morning and I've just
come from a meeting with my staff here
in Whitney and I met with my
constituency staff in London but I
thought about this long and hard over
the summer and I've decided the right
thing to do is to stand down as the
Member of Parliament for Whitney
there'll be a by-election I'll give the
Conservative candidate my full support
but in my view in with modern politics
with the circumstances of my resignation
it isn't really possible to be a proper
backbench MP as a former prime minister
I think everything you do will become a
big distraction and a big diversion from
what the government needs to do for our
country and I support Theresa May I
think she's got off to a great start I
think she can be a strong Prime Minister
for our country and I don't want to be
that distraction I want Whitney to have
a new MP who can play a full part in
parliamentary and political life without
being a distraction I want to thank
everybody here in West Oxfordshire
who've been so supportive it has been a
great honor and privilege to serve this
area and to serve these brilliant people
I'm going to go on living locally I'll
go on supporting the local causes and
local charities that make this such a
great place in our country but obviously
I'm gonna have to start to build a life
outside Westminster I hope I'll continue
to contribute in terms of public service
and of course contribute to this country
that I love so much
now you could continue supporting to
resume and the new government from the
back benches that is possible by
resigning in the way that you are today
you are leaving yourself open to the
charge that you are snubbing the Prime
Minister you cannot support everything
that she is trying to do well I spoke to
Theresa May and she was very
understanding about this decision I
support her I support what she's doing
she's got off to a cracking start
obviously I'm gonna have my own views
about different issues people would know
that and that's really the point as a
former prime minister it is very
difficult I think to sit as a
backbencher and not be an enormous
diversion and distraction from what the
government's doing I don't want to be
that distraction I want Whitney to have
an MP that can play a full role in
parliamentary and political life in a
way that I think I would find very
difficult if not impossible one of the